but right now we got to do some rising
star games David Sam thank you very much
for coming along to our wonderful little
cash a pleasure to the you guys are in
town you've got like a like a whole host
of games that you shown off to price
I've just down the road from it's like
two blocks away no using not even we're
too lazy relations come in here show
what you gave every cater do you go yeah
yeah and we want to use your sweet self
as well exactly and then 25 minutes when
you're sweating balls you could jump
away really hang out sideways right now
it's quite cool in here it's pretty hot
it yeah this is like a nice part of the
year for San Francisco right oh yeah
it's real nice the lighting actually
makes me look tan which is crazy really
yeah cuz I'm like transparent mean
exactly yes cousin I do I get you guys
beat maybe yeah you got too many games
to show so we're concentrating on to
today yeah at first one up try that's
one is try yeah so I and play try to try
and tell me about dry right I'm gonna
succeed in tell you go through okay so
try is a it's a 3d puzzle platformer
it's developed by journaling developers
racking entertainment great name you
know the right King is right you know
right all right I do it's what all those
rats yeah get tied up together and all
of that tail I'm pretty sure as a
character in a ninja turtles also a
wrecking I hope so yeah it's all the
feces and yeah works well okay so try
sets out to create fun in one of the
more unexpected places which is
trigonometry okay yeah yeah sohcahtoa
baby did you have fun with trigonometry
in school Oh hate it was like hated I I
was not good at mathematics whatsoever
history english okay well the upside is
you have to be good at math to plate
right god so you're in the realm of the
old gods and one of the Gods has gone
missing and using the power of the try
your your mission is going to hunt them
down mmm try for us right it's not a
triforce we can't say Dreyfus college
right now it's good to try power yeah
but ours is in all caps and so it's as
simple as clicking the three points of
the triangle
and you can create a triangle anyway you
spree road and then soon as you touch it
or you can right-click on it as well but
you becomes physical and you can walk on
it so this is when you first get the tri
power so it's very simple to begin with
it's kind of just teaching the player
how to use it but you can do a lot more
stuff later in the game so you can defy
gravity with it so the gravity becomes
centered on the try you can also deflect
spirits and lasers with it so we're
keeping it nice and simple here for the
we keep it a nice simple discover that
sweet and all I neglected I collect okay
she just stole it sucked up my status
not recover your special so they're
actually they're just bonuses so for the
completest inside of you you can delete
triangle you can down trial is right
with bright clicking and the destruction
of triangles is just as essential as the
creation creation of triangles so it's a
gangster for ya ya got to be a flex you
want to try and complete the game about
deleting triangles you can have a hard
time not for sure so ghost dude here is
basically you yes this is the monk he's
kind of a guy your spirit okay yeah and
he also tells us about the controversial
and powers of the dry because it does
have a tendency to send people insane
okay okay but there's more about that in
the game and that's a big one you're
gonna be get over encumbered with like
Luke wants your head of the school boy I
am never slots in the bag let's say
these red foxes they're the ones that
are kind of the keys to the levels and
they're our primary goal and we can kind
of find out where they are by pressing H
and yours you get a general kind of
guide but you're not sure how cry how
close will have far okay you see ya just
little beacons pop up on the overlay can
you have as many triangles out as you
please I'm pretty sure you can just go
absolutely nuts yeah excellent there's
also a score attack mode like a
challenge mode and it's about how quick
you can do how many bonus statues you
can get and also in how few trying to be
nice awesome I Chris sakes Jim on
gamespot chart asked i will try BMS
keyboard only i'm a pc gamer but a lazy
one will you have controller support all
right and right there with him
and I'm my target run and I think which
all the support we try to keep control
of sport and as many games as possible
hopefully yeah you know I think it's
also a matter of ideally it will start
up with you know default keyboard mouse
combo but yeah if you know if the
support is there for the community you
know if enough people get behind the
game I think that it will be something
that's possible down the line at what
stage is this up because you guys kind
of work with a lot of them indie
developers who are some of which are
using early access some of which are
kind of have been out on platforms like
this or in the past is this available at
the moment what stage is this is not
available right now it's going to be
launched on the 9th [ __ ] over oh man
it suck yep it's in the final stages
it's just get a bill for playing is
probably about ninety percent complete
yeah and there's a purely single-player
campaign kind of at the moment yeah
awesome so there is the challenge mode
and that's fully supported by online
you're putting all your lose in here
yeah well this is the kind of portal out
of here okay I just need my final
stature Indiana Jones desk yeah just got
to steal a bunch of stuff that was only
changing agent people just redecorating
you're not taking it with sure you're
just moving around yeah inconveniencing
them and relocating punish way at the
place okay this is likely to start right
back to the start but we didn't have the
power of the try so we couldn't reach
that one at first I grabbed this
sweetness yeah so this is the third
stage every yeah if I so the first two
were kind of just your tutorial stage is
kind of had a little bit of hand-holding
well is never bad thing these days know
what I'm puzzle platforming it seems to
be pretty much a requirement I'll get
out here start doing in it into the
portal which is Peter so you can see
this is kind of a summary of my gameplay
experience I've got 14 tries created in
my time and I've only had a poxy two
statues found of the 11 and you did it
faster than that but we were just idling
before the show start exactly it's not
the [ __ ] oh it's the time really high
yeah I was like 80 minutes oh wow I'm
not bet you can do this one faster let's
go i'm guessing the layering mechanics
on top of the regular triangle one's
ever get a circle
it will just wouldn't sit in all you
just spoil the sequel oh yeah good boy
yeah hexagon alright that's all it even
made the Pentagon it just filled hex
caps should we give it should we give
some fresh hands ago this guy yeah
absolutely i give Chris he's doing here
okay oh yeah how do you see just push
this thing over here we go as much fun
as it is watching somebody who's
completed that level seven million times
yeah past at the fresh eyes all right
that's where it's all at pressing H will
give you a kind of see through guided
you're looking for yeah my Ma's hurt so
bad so okay okay get off that Fox juice
just go ahead over here soon see whats
whys all right there we go you're frying
ghal tonic I not true boom I told you
can try and run and jump this or less
choice so the initial like I guess you
like initially you're trying to I might
be a range em then dr. fine it's you
yeah yeah do you Far Cry got this oh
you're so Parker right ok so if that you
can edit snow good can actually alter
them on the fly as well so you can
really you can also bear with triangles
off of your existing tunnels which can
lead to some interesting creation act
like a square am i right that's fitting
that will get you upon me yeah restless
boilers all right such a good bundle
we're stuff goes missing here in the
office all the time I reckon it's great
so good at this yeah except I just knock
it on the ground yeah alright we can
knock all these boxes around like that
oh you want to get them all out of your
lead get outta my way boxes
grab them plan wire in the twit shot
asks how many stages will there be
currently 16 levels cool and there's no
ability to like create your own or share
their only not currently I mean not
asking developer that with the game
develop yeah had time to think about
what next you see a scissor 16 ones
asking do you guys have a price yet for
this bad boy and did you say look at the
PR guy which right now and none of the
pc titles they have lined up are going
to be over $15 okay we're all trying to
shoot at 12 99 yeah and below and it'll
be on steam so looking forward to future
of releases and sales and all sorts of
cool deal 60 know it's there it's rising
star games 10th anniversary oh yeah so
they've been around for 10 years so
they're kind of they're ramping up real
quick with a lot of cool titles well it
seems like you guys have got a bunch of
stuff working on the Lord yeah who seems
very new to us we've had collabo and
deadly premonition yeah now we're just
kind of we really like that kind of
indie experience where you can support
these guys who can do an interesting
product what get on it got it get long
I'm just gonna get one of them and you
hold up the H key I think it's behind
you it should be over hey you go to bind
us on the hell you go to other news 10
that I know he's already gonna beat me
[ __ ] you all right Chris he looks a
little more amazing pieces of art and
then we're gonna swap on to a new game
when you're doing be fine just create
yep these triangles in it drop in
triangle nobody'll no big deal boom is
that your first one of those my perfect
big red yeah three big red where's
isn'ta Moore's more big real love that
it's like a tripping balls every time
what there's another one there the layer
levels in the game they feature a lot
more mechanics and puzzles and stuff and
they've got a lot longer to complete I
mean these we're still kind of in the
tutorial and setting other player this
day first quarter the game so all right
one more for more pressure leaving you
like
see ya I'd say just take your ludes and
find out who the next cottage oh the way
their name into your through I know
you're going the right way down the hall
yeah yeah yeah and it got it a Vita baby
it's like super high position money ya
gotta get the girl get is a switch
there's a switch on the wall behind you
the only other way hey yeah it's great
now we're like now it's like to catch
co-op single-player video games have
done that hella the best kind of whoa
what's how it goes he's the monkeys he's
your guides I'm not sure these are Hawks
if he's a rabbit I seasonable years over
the top so it is yeah triangle use a
bunny I'm no dias right where we don't
worry bed you like the upside down
triangle trees so get ahead here one
more you got it go away I have a feeling
this next one's gonna be difficult why'd
you delete those oh here I'll tell you
triangle triangles that are under that
one trying on the right so you can't
delete that one first oh cuz its
supporting wing and that's behind us
it's a load-bearing triangle it is
actually can't bring it all crashing not
going that down so this is just like a
good example of how you can build
triangles and dad to other triangles not
just connected to the environment right
so what so showing the player how they
can look this Madeline I was like when
you're in school and you jump up you at
the doorway yeah yeah high five the
dorsal on a golf on Fox I 10 you're
right yup foxy Fox gotta know got it
nice that won't always be sad loss is no
time yeah yeah anyways I talking in the
whole game there's a story behind that a
story behind every obstacle spoiler
there's a floating thing all right let's
knock it on to the next day right you
guys have got a bunch of games you shift
on through them keep on rockin with our
sweet little table it's the best that's
pretty neat nice work so tries Aetna's
first week of October's alright
goodnight yeah cool every night now
crimoya is that apron answered her Maya
yeah so little play down a second but
we're you've got a bunch of other games
that you're not showing here today I can
give us kind of the rundown on some of
those bad boys Hopa um topless kind of
like a very inward thought crazy
I don't know he wanted to grab the sand
it's very it's it's insane it looks like
you're in a nightmare asylums not the
one Jeremy is not the one you were
saying is some sort of weird thing where
you create a brother version of yourself
yeah evil imaginary friend yes yes
side-scroller service Jeremy saris our
staff mystic there's a side-scrolling
puzzle game but it's very dark
mysterious and very abstract as well so
it takes the puzzles very abstract so
it's not you know me like doing it
logical is kind of you got a really open
your mind to get to it but it's yeah
very dark very mysterious cool I know
that yet all their titles they have
coming up or very all have very unique
art styles i tries very um Eastern was
like kind of looking an asian-themed and
Crimea is very futuristic it almost has
a pretty vivid though tradition as well
yeah Kraken Empire yeah right so if I
you guys only partner with indie
developers who've got really good news
yeah it's a wrap top of our check
register it was like a name check croyle
were Empire they're all names inspired
by China Mieville books s'ok reminds
actually been like available for a while
I think it's not right or as if I
remember seeing this on desura what got
a year ago or something is our right
another different version of it okay
okay okay I think they had like an
earlier version got it show the dad I
don't know this menu is a it's pretty
cool isn't it stooping you read space
age I know do you wanna yeah that one
says up you learn it hey yeah so I'm
crack an empire there a Spanish
developer and they're big fans the retro
2d side-scrolling kind of schmutsing and
they wanted to bring that that craziness
into a 3d world and so they've done a
number of things to bridge that gap
firstly we've got six planes of freedom
so we've got your left right forward
back which then makes a difference is
you got your up and down so you work
vertical and you've also got your
spinaroonie spinaroonie yeah and your
pit 60 oh baby and what's cool is you
can apply your boost
any any one of those vertices six
directions we've all very basic hi
everyone its first time I played the
center calling yours I was an oculus
rift anyone could you imagine okay so
this is the orange world with the
ownership you kind of go through
everyone's respective worlds to begin
with and then you start experimenting
with different ships one of the first
things they've tried to make it like
asha maps as the enemies of programs
come in front of you there's a there's a
number of interesting AI dynamics and
it's got progressive chromite has
progressive difficulty also so if you're
you know excelling at the game at a
rapid pace it'll ramp up the difficulty
of AI aren't you down what if you're
just walking into a bunch of stuff I
need good probably fail I get my head in
the game this is a lot harder a game to
demo live yeah I can buzz around quite
easily but when you get into the mode
into the zone it gets really quick i
need to get my advance because notice do
you like playing sideways with their
ship it like there's no down left or
right in space gotcha tails honors the
enemy's gate is down it has a lot of
unique mechanics that i think a lot of
people are gonna utilize notice those
gigantic space coffins that you're
flying around this oh I hope those are
totally big space coffins and but as it
has a weird feel like it's it's like
part starfox park calling wars part res
are ya everything it's it's really cool
and the soundtrack is actually done even
though we're from we're just fitted from
our nice back pain okay um that's right
sorry goodbye uh yeah you've no they're
from Spain they actually wanted two guys
move the guy who did the soundtrack OST
lives in san cisco else wait yeah good
Betty mine and he's actually a good
principle sound way forwards
composer spot little boys our crew then
oh these games the difficulty is often
like the sort of I don't know a folks
who like playing these kind of games
like that ramp up in difficulty head
challenges this bad boy again I agree i
say i say to the dude who's already
dying in the first level it's not one of
those games like i made the mistake when
i first first couple times I played it
just thinking I could just fly from the
checkpoint to checkpoint and make it and
the enemies you know as long as I dodge
the enemies they wouldn't bother me so
are you predominantly trying to hit
those six out of ten checkpoints have
you be killin them basically just sort
of keep them at bay rather than like of
a score kind of yeah so the main bring
the story night but then there's also a
score attack which scores you on stuff
you kill and time
and that's where were the leader boards
and stuff we're going to be so that's
where the real competition starts sy
Shiro and the gamespot child asks is the
air if the airs programs to common front
of you could you heard them in front of
you for massive combos you can like let
them in front and kind of backup and
yeah I into them and one of the ships
one of the ships in carmine also has
like a targeting so if you held down the
attack button whatever it will actually
auto target auto targeting all of them
so you could Corral all of them your
onion there are some slight tricky ones
though the attached lasers you and start
draining your HP so you oh really you're
trying to herd them yeah yeah the NPC's
a slightly dos honest I thankfully for
you yep otherwise I'd probably be dead
by now it's pretty great looking I'm not
sure what are different ships yeah oh oh
we're just going to try another ship
show you so it's four ships all of them
have very unique play styles and
strengths and weaknesses so that was
kind of the all-rounder ship it's got a
shotgun so you have a primary that you
can fire constantly in the u.s.
secondary that has a very low cooldown
joystiq experts only this one says
medicine keyboard man every yeah we're
going to ask you where you've already
gotten full controller support say okay
those lazy game is when there's a come
on out time cover 24th oh okay mix month
again you guys got a busy October right
this one looks like a civil war tank
from the side oh yeah brother say this
is mine i / it's like i say so it's yeah
ok so the precise thing that we didn't
show was you can actually go in the
first person kind of a cockpit view tube
how sweet and there's a kind of
in-between stage as well
but this ship is a heavily reliant on
accuracy so it really helps because just
the laser to drain to HP yeah oh no no
that was enemy's base all right that's
your season I thought it was like a
reward risk reward thing yeah so that's
the secondary or a special attack so
unlike traditional shmups have bombed
then you have unlimited amount of
secondary firepower but it actually
takes along a longer time to recharge
board this ship specifically yeah yeah
the game for any [ __ ] like I'm ship that
you have in the game there's four total
ships know all their secondary weapons
full take our time and do their
secondaries have different attributes
absolutely how many ships are in it for
total I want about levels how long is
this bad boy is a mostly school attack
stuff or what about the camping I had
not completed it and I don't know
there's four words one for each ship mmm
I'm kind of racing for you doing the
checkpoints all of them kind of have
like a side wall going on so you can go
and explore the different areas there
are a few puzzles in there as well and
and then once you complete all the
worlds they become kind of score attack
zones and after lose any ship in any
world I mean crack and Empire they want
to keep all the ships competitive and
we're really looking forward to when the
game gets our and the pros get on it and
they've mastered it within a week I'm
making you guys look like chumps yeah
that happens I did that with clogged 00
me and the people of helping a shout out
to Chester okay we've got a boss coming
up here all right okay fell dead boss
it's very subtle but if you have to
scream Oh traditional shmup fashion oh
so big the warning
I kill this honeycomb dude yeah we gotta
explain first person I believe in you oh
I just got our booth as in first person
as you can see if I was a last-minute
feast and it'll still keep your distance
a lot in the bosses I did this road
that's what the Lay's is built for this
is the censorship if we have time it
would be awesome to show everyone the
first Mel a spaceship in history now
there's a spaceship yeah we retract that
there's an old shmup Carol's anything it
was another hand there's another male a
spaceship yeah that's second best
fortunately we're back in melee spish
the coolest phone rings dawn is he dead
he's gone nice work yep Bragg's faster
well done that's quickly do you dump it
oh we gotta we gotta keep we gotta we
gotta power on through such as the
wonder of the lobby dudes thank you so
much coming out of chromoly is about
29th is that right 24th of October for
whom I am I looking for like a high five
is owning share another 29th try will be
october nine sweet yeah awesome and you
guys are showing off all your wares
downtown at the moment best of luck with
that and yeah well get in contact when
this bad boys around we'll also have
another play of them thank you so much
for coming on